plyer staplers open and close like
pliers to tackle fastening jobs with
quick precision making these stapler
starts with the cover plate a press
wields up to 176 tons of force to shape
steel blanks to a slope profile a robot
inserts tracks into nickel steel casings
these are the vertical staple tracks for
the front of the stapler tools Bend tabs
on the ends of the casings to fasten the
two parts another robot serves up covers
for the staplers magazines - an
automated welder the welder fuses an
assembly attachment to each cover next
up is the die plate this is the part
that shapes and closes the staple during
stapling an automated system screws an
iron u-bolt attachment to the die plate
a robot then inserts the spring block
the part that allows the stapler to
spring back to its original position
after use meanwhile at the next station
a robot places a piece of precision cut
steel on a mold
a press drives it into the mold to shape
it into the stapler body that holds all
the working components more robots then
work in perfect sequence to install
thick metal pins across the stapler body
these pins brace the stapler structure
but that's not all some of the staplers
working parts will hook on to these pins
workers are ready to assemble all the
working parts the assembler slides the
front staple track into place and
inserts the staple pusher guide into the
body she positions a metal plate over
the guide and screws everything in place
through holes in the body of the stapler
the assembler Clips a retaining ring
around each screw next up is the driver
this part attaches staples one at a time
during stapling after installing it the
assembler inserts the spring-loaded
pusher and hooks the end on the staple
guide another worker assembles the
handle that allows the stapler to be
wielded with plier like accuracy he
secures the handle with a rolling
fastener this rolling fastener
indirectly bears down on the staples to
apply pressure during stapling these
plier staplers are now ready for the
workplace or with a few quick crunches
they'll help keep the paperwork in order